عن هذه الاستهدافات هذه الغارات وما
يقولها الجيش الاسرائيلي اضافه
الى ما قاله حزب الله واثر ما اعلنه في
المقابل جيفار البديري من الجليل
الاعلى بيان محدث قبل قليل وهذا ليس على
العاده التي جرت خلالها الايام الماضيه ان
يصدر بيانين للجيش الاسرائيلي في ذات
اليوم في ساعات قليله حسن في البيان
المحدث الجيش يقول انه قسم القصف على
مرحلتين بمعنى ان الدبابات والمدفعيه
الاسرائيليه قامت بقصف بلدات
اي الظاهره ط حرف وعيت الشعب اما الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه فقصت بنى تحتيه قال
انها تابعه ل حزب الله في مناطق كفار كلا
وايضا نقطه مراقبه في بلده بليده في
الجنوب اللبناني ولكن قبل ذلك كان قد اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف مواقع تحوي ايضا
بنى تحتيه عسكريه لحزب الله وابرز ما فيها
وهذا ما يتحدث عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي وكانه
انجاز وايضا الاعلام الاسرائيلي بانه تم
قصف احد مدرجات للطائرات العسكريه التابعه
لحزب الله وبعض ال المحللين والمراسلين
العسكريين للجيش الاسرائيلي يقولون ان هذا
المدرج للطائرات يتم استخدامه من قبل قوات
ايرانيه موجوده في الجنوب اللبناني وكان
ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل يومين قد قصف
مباني قال انها مواقع عسكريه ايضا
تستخدمها قوات ايرانيه وذلك لم يصدر من
الجانب الاخر اي من جانب حزب الله ولكن
ايضا في ساعات الصباح الاولى كان هناك
استهداف من
قبل حزب الله بطائرات مسيره على الاقل
نتحدث عن طائره مسيره مفخخه اتجاه موقع
كفار بلوم في منطقه سهل الحوله في
الجليل الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه لم يكن
هناك اي اصابات او اضرار ولكن مجرد
الاعتراف بانه كان هناك مسيرات مخففه وقام
باغلاق المنطقه بالكامل من كافه المحاور
ووضع حواجز عسكريه دون ان ي صافرات هذا
الانذار معناه اننا نتحدث عن موقع عسكري
لكن لم يتم الحديث عن ان هذا الموقع يحتوي
على اي اي مضادات ارضيه او حتى صواريخ
القبه الحديديه في هذا الموقع هو فقط تحدث
عن ان المسيرات المفخخه اتجهت صوب هذا
الموقع تم التصدي لها ولكنها يبدو انها
سقطت في هذا الموقع دون اصابات او اضرار
ايضا لازال الجيش الاسرائيلي يحقق فيما
حدث قبل ثلاثه ايام تحديدا في منطقه
المطله عندما اطلقت على الاقل قذيفتي هاون
من داخل الجنوب اللبناني اجاه بلده المطله
اكتشف الجيش الاسرائيلي حسب ما يقول
الناطق العسكري بان هاتين القذيفتين تحوي
على مواد فسفوريه ليتضح لاحقا ان هذه
القذائف هي اصلا اسرائيليه فبقي السؤال
حتى هذه اللحظه كيف وصلت اسلحه او قذائف
هاون اسرائيليه الى حزب الله واعاد قصفها
مجددا الى داخل الاراضي الاسرائيليه شكرا